(applaudissements)
- Après une fin de semaine
de réflexion en famille,
Dominique Anglade
jette l'éponge.
DOMINIQUE ANGLADE, cheffe
démissiorti libéral
- J'ai informé le président du
parti ce matin de ma démission à
titre de cheffe du Parti libéral
du Québec. J'annonce également
que je quitterai mes fonctions
de députée de Saint-Henri/
Sainte-Anne le 1er décembre.
- Dominique Anglade!
(applaudissements)
- Élupour la première
fois en 2015, Dominique Anglade
est devenue la première femme
à la tête du Parti libéral
il y a un peu plus de deux ans.
- Allez-vous être là?
- (foule): Oui!
- La dernière campagne
électorale a été difficile
et avec le pire résultat jamais
connu par le parti, la pression
était déjà forte.
- Comme plusieurs d'entre-vous,
j'ai été déçue.
- Mais la crise provoquée
par l'expulsion du caucus
de la députée Marie-Claude
Nichols a donné le coup
de grâce.
PIERRE ARCAND, ancien député
Parti libéral du Québec
- Il y avait de la part de
plusieurs députés et membres du
parti un certain mécontentement,
alors je pense qu'elle a compris
la situation.
- On n'a pas le luxe d'être mint
les Québécois n'ont que faire.
- Le schisme est toutefois plus
profond dans les rangs libéraux.
- Le Parti libéral du Québec
doit opérer un renouvellement
de son offre politique,
mais aussi de sa façon
de faire de la politique.
- Deux visions s'opposent :
une fracture avec le passé
en misant sur la transition
écologique, ce qu'a tenté
de faire Dominique Anglade,selo.
CARLOS LEITAO, ancien député
Parti libéral du Québec
- C'est ça qui n'a pas collé,
c'est ça que les membres du
parti, un bon nombre d'entre
eux, ont eu beaucoup de
résistance à faire ce virage-là.
DAVID BIRNBAUM, ancien députcieé
Parti libéral du Québec
- Moi, je suis préoccupé par
l'importance de nous renouveler
comme Parti libéral du Québec.
- Alors que d'autres refusent
de faire table rase...
- Quand on dit renouveler,
dire presque commencer
au tout début. Ce qui ne doit
pas, à mon avis, être le cas.
Je pense qu'il faut faireévolue.
- Un parti à la croisée
des chemins avec un caucus
mais qui, dans un rare
moment d'unité, salue tour
à tour sur les médias sociaux
l'engagement et le dévouement
cheffe.
Le premier ministre François
Legault aussi reco
son courage et son humilité.
FRANTZ BENJAMIN,
député, PLQ, Viau
- C'est cette dignitée,
dont elle a fait montre dans
son dernier discours de départ à
titre de cheffe du Parti libéral
du Québec. Vous comprenez
e journée-là, c'est
la journée Dominique Anglade.
- Mais la question de qui
lui succèdera est sur toutes
les lèvres. Déjà des noms
t, Denis Coderre,
Sophie Brochu, Pierre Moreau,
Marwah Rizqy, Pierre Fortin,
mais avant la course à la
chefferie, il faudra nommerun ce
début des travaux parlementaires
le 29 novembre prochain.
Ici Jacaudrey Charbonneau,
Radio-Canada, Québec.